do you feel differently about your
season now that it's been a little while
now that you're separated from it for a
while I still feel emotional I do I do
yeah I do what do you get emotional
about I think it's just and you know
I've never read the finale
no like I will never be able to rewatch
that in your life yeah why because it's
heartbreaking to me to watch really
effortless this is very easy
I know I tried to rewatch it a bunch of
times to numb myself to the feelings and
I just never watched it and it was just
really hard and how was life now because
we know it did not work out with you
with you and Kevin what is your life
like now obviously dating must be very
different having been the bachelorettes
I'm kind of seeing somebody now but it's
casual I'm still I mean I haven't been
out there like dating dating okay
just someone that I used to know and
we've been friends for a long time so
I'm kind of trying that out I couldn't
imagine myself actually going on like
dates and getting out there and dating
dating again I think that that would
take a long time for me to get that
place from the show I feel like I'm
really aware of my means right and my
want yeah and I want to make sure that
I'm paying attention to that what advice
do you give to say Chris The Bachelor
just don't be afraid to ask questions
yeah I was put in this position where I
felt really empowered to do that so I
think being open and taking advantage of
that position you're put in to feel free
to ask the questions that you want to
and be a little bit selfish why are you
here like what are you doing here like
oh come on go into the bar like you
don't have the problem meeting anybody I
don't go to the bar okay so walking down
the street like you don't TV completely
honest I don't but I have very high
standards they're really playing him up
as the lonely bachelor a lot of my
experiences in baseball and in life have
have come with me being alone not really
having a special person to share it with
I think he actually is like that in real
life I've heard that he's a really
private guy so I'm interested to see how
it plays out with this being such a
public